i was talking to mr beast about that
because he hung out with gordon
you've heard of him i was a private jet
you know
uh and uh and he was like yeah he's he's
just really serious about his food like
you he because he would he'd be all
jokey and fun because obviously like his
willy wonka [ __ ] was like
not real cooking yeah but when he ate
the food he like took it so seriously
and would retort like very seriously and
like meanly but it's just because he
loves food so much yeah yeah i was like
it's crazy to love something and be that
knowledgeable about it imagine having
like you know gordon ramsay flies out to
you and he's like oh yeah we'll go get
up for food just pick a restaurant
you're like oh [ __ ]
you pick up pick a restaurant
it must be awful dude you want to hear
something crazy i think this will be
fine because it'll be released by the
time this is out but uh
mr beast was doing a no eating for 30
day challenge yeah which which he told
me about on stream before yeah which is
incredibly hard yeah i think i lost
maybe five yeah you know five i could i
could do like one
you could do more than a day one hour
i've been in america too long to do this
you did less an hour in this setting and
then
i
uh he lasted so uh mr beast goes for
like quite a while yeah the reason he
cracked is because gordon ramsay cooked
him a meal
and gordon ramsay's like yeah part of
the video was that just unintentionally
it was unintentional because he was
filming willy wonka and then gordon for
his own youtube was like i'll cook you
like this egg meal and he cooks it up
and jimmy's like oh i can't eat and
grown's like well you're gonna have my
meal
and like imagine not eating for like two
weeks and then gordon ramsay is there
how to break him out the most succulent
meal
that is like your anime waifu coming to
life on your no fap challenge
like
second last day of no not november
speaking of which do you watch hentai
not often i used to do you have like
favorites in high school i would just
mainline [ __ ] one piece naruto hentai
it was just pictures no it's just
pictures yeah yeah well because the
reader he's the three portrait person i
would watch porn on my psp
which couldn't load videos
yet the [ __ ] out yeah
and it couldn't load my brother's videos
i'd be like this that would be on my
website pixel go in another pixel so i
would just watch i would look at
pictures
and uh and pictures of like porn
pictures are like they're really
aggressive oh yeah yeah like porn like
irl porn shoots it's like it's like a
lot yeah come everywhere and i was like
like i'm a kid i'm like
too much for me
yeah that's when i was i'm in high
school 14 15. and uh and i'd go on
benders too like marathon jerk off days
and so
to the psp to the ps4 making this sound
like a [ __ ] training arc so yeah i i
not it every day for a year straight i
would try to go for my record
i was like you missed a beast dude it
was like 18.
in one day in one day and by the end of
it it's just going to cop it bro my
dick's just going
it just dust flies out do 18 in one day
i'm doing 18 in one day you didn't know
i can do 18 and one i i believe that's
not even i would wake up i would do a
few i would a few i would do a few what
you can't back-to-back yeah i can cover
a lethal weapon drake 96-97 i was i was
in that [ __ ] connor this is back this
is like peak balls drop you are nothing
but a horny child i i mean i've been
horny i mean 18 times a day 18 is beyond
reason i think it was like a mythbusters
savage [ __ ] gun is it possible
well adam let me try to jerk you off
here with this walrus mustache nuts bust
the beard
you could imagine doing like five or six
five is the most i've done is eight yes
i think i was doing that and that's like
more casual like oh i'm just that's more
casual [ __ ] this is like this was like a
goal this was a goal this is what this
is why smash players smell so [ __ ]
bad this is unrelated because they would
do that
and then rock up to the invitation i
can't wait for you to have fun at anime
going to smell amazing isn't it
you're coming yeah for like 18 times
the expo
uh yeah so i was i was going for a
record okay look maybe what purpose like
just because i wanted to see what i
could do i wanted to go further than
beyond come on okay and uh limit testing
his own dick so
hentai was helping you yes yeah yeah
which characters
uh dude
i could see the doubt
[Music]
[Music]
she was dating the guy with the the
blades oh
the one who into like older ones yeah
she's in the older one oh you like the
mouse
yeah i was in a milf i think who isn't
but i mean she's not a milf because
she's still like she's like a 25 year
old yeah she's an older older adult to a
15 year old is that a milk
it's not a true like i think a true milf
i would never
it's true
like a true mother i would be like oh
that is that is what what did marlene
say to you when you first never see you
no no no no no no it's prozy oh yeah
yeah well what happened personally
rocked out within five minutes
like uh but you know like 16 year olds
can be moms right
that's the intro
that's what she said keep it casual
around yeah yeah
wait so are you watching you don't watch
stuff anymore no
no
yeah where'd you find the time where
would you find the time i don't jerk off
much no i guess well yeah after 18 a day
i wouldn't
age like 50 years
you need like a month or so
yeah yeah she needs a rest saga
uh yeah i think it's it's like you know
what horniness is like the devil of
working hard that's very true
you know it's like it's the one thing
and so like i've all been i've been
about working hard and also like have a
girlfriend but yeah yeah it's like like
i even before i had a girlfriend i just
went like anti-sex mode yeah i was like
i was like shut off sex drive work hard
and i was like just strange that does
happen sometimes i just get in like a
transfer like four or five days where i
don't even think about it yeah yeah and
then like the next three i'll be like i
need a job you're so much more powerful
yeah if you don't give in
you reckon yeah because you're actually
just like focused like what if you have
like a wet dream though
i do i do have i used to have them so
often
what you were jacking
it was like it was like every month or
every two months
i would just bust my pants when i slept
it happened during the summerathon
yeah during the show yeah did it
actually because i didn't jerk off at
all during the subathon and i didn't
hook up with my girlfriend because you
know we didn't have sex because yeah
you're online
yeah i'm alive every minute how many
times did it happen like once just once
was it cool was it um i did definitely i
was live the whole time i mean like
it wasn't like caught like [ __ ] you
know shamu drops down and a wave comes
up yeah it's not what you want
i just woke up and i was like
and then i went to the bathroom and i
hobbled over and i was like that's funny
and then i told stream like three weeks
after the seven ended
just enough to let the shame and you get
it yes yeah right because i didn't want
to tell them that morning because i was
like this is too close to the right i
think you wouldn't hear the end of it
right yeah yeah yeah but yeah that that
happens doesn't happen as much anymore
but wow like my current roommate slime
who's the guy who got me into streaming
i slept over his house and we were going
to a smash tournament the next day and i
woke up just [ __ ] trousers full
and i had to go to him and i'd be like i
look i'm coming to you on the day of
your daughter's wedding for some
underwear
and he was like yeah that's right
oh my god
but i've then you unlocked the power of
work
yeah i mean yeah i uh definitely feel
like less drive to when i'm when i'm
hardly working yeah
i don't know it gets to a point where
there's a build up right and then if you
you try to concentrate on work and then
for some reason like you you just carved
on your shoulder yeah you got a devil
no one will be as bad as soda pop and
you hear he's an insane man
because he will be on stream he used to
do this back in the day more so but he'd
just be on stream and then be like i'm
horny i'm gonna go jerk off and you just
leave a stream on and he would leave for
like five minutes come back and be like
all right what are we doing today and
like like shamelessly what on a
consistent basis there are still many
clips you can find of this and i was
like to have that
lack of shame would be so impressive
isn't there a clip of him [ __ ]
himself as well
i mean that's just art yeah that's
that's dedication yeah
i can't just kind of
how could you just not wait till the
stream's over yeah no just sorry what's
what happened
i just [ __ ] himself once you just [ __ ]
himself on stream i think it was like a
fart and it just came and then hear me
he immediately was just like he shot
himself on stream what's up guys i mean
what's the last time you shoot yourself
high school yeah really
much much younger middle school probably
dude i've got some scares yeah yeah
first like three months i was dating
cutie i [ __ ] myself in front of her i
was so sad how did that happen
what happened i just became horribly ill
and i was staying at her place
and i was just [ __ ] myself
constantly but it was like a new
relationship you know she's she's there
yeah yeah that's how i know she's day
one road
but still it's not great to [ __ ] in
front of her and have [ __ ] underwear and
be like and be like a poopy
poo yeah but she was very cool about it
how did you explain it
i just had to suck it up and be like
i [ __ ] myself
i said it coolly though though
you said it as coolly as you could
[ __ ] myself like babe
[ __ ] myself if you look down there there
might be some [ __ ] for you
and she's like oh there is a vile
creature
speaking you are sick so that that
doesn't count yeah well i'd say like
[ __ ] yourself not being sick i mean
i have no [ __ ] that's negligence
yeah if you show yourself not sick you
are negligent and you are not taking
good care of yourself
you either drink way too much or you are
just not get those shits when i've drank
too much no i don't yeah it depends it's
it's
the next morning right no no you don't
no no i don't no i'm five percent welsh
so i never put myself
[Music]
so every time you drink you get the
shits afterwards yeah in the morning i'm
like immediately i think oh i feel
horrible i think me too yeah and it's
not it's never a pretty one no it's
never a pretty one guessing white clover
fixes everything you also can root boot
and loot in australia
do you know that one what
what does that mean
you you you
so you [ __ ] root so you [ __ ] yeah
and then you boot you throw up and then
you steal whoever your [ __ ] things
and then you leave
it's the root boot and loot
who told you uh australian i know i mean
i i haven't heard it personally but i
believe it do you know what a meat
uh a
hold up
do you know what a meat lottery is
i thought
yeah yeah in australia they'll have
lotteries where the town comes together
and you can win a bunch of meat and you
can just buy little vouchers to win the
meat that's that's in like kind of small
countries yeah when you said meat
lottery i was thinking something
like meat spin like around there yeah
they turn the lights off they play who's
in my mouth yeah that's right you get
is that a dildo
it's like the try next youtube trend
yeah
did you ever see that yeah what the the
is it a dildo or a dick no yeah yeah
that's a youtube video yeah yeah that is
a youtube video what could be like a
screen right and you would just see the
dudes like head and torso yeah and
there'd be a screen and then someone
would put
something in his butt yeah and they'd be
like you have to guess is it a dildo
and then the guy's like no that's
definitely a dildo that's that's a dildo
and then you go to the next one and he
goes no this one's the dildo
was he you had to be 100 right right
i didn't watch enough oh come on i just
saw the title and i was like wow no mill
snow me yeah yeah
actually i couldn't believe it was on
youtube yeah it is crazy you can just
look up like nude yoga and then
immediately you hit get hit with
thumbnails that's just coochie yeah
yeah it's wild how youtube decides to uh
there's just less shoes in there it's
tight i think because the alternative is
like you're on twitch and then you're
constantly scared of like yeah like a
nipple flash your butt flash and you're
like i'm gonna get banned but on youtube
it's like we'll just hit you with this
yellow button yeah yeah and that's it
you don't get banned so where's your
stream of you watching nude yoga you
know it's coming
i would feel terrible i don't want to be
like a child sexual awakening like i
don't think most of my viewers are
children i think they're mostly like
older
but there's a chance
they're all adults
who watch me come on guys they're all
mature uh but there's definitely a kid
and you have like a weird sexual
awakening and i don't want to be there
for it
that's all i'm saying
is like thank you if you didn't watch
that nude yoga yeah i didn't tune into
that stream i want to meet my girlfriend
yeah he's like no i don't want to hear
this do it on your own
brother oh my god